we're here in Turin in Italy and behind
me is the Cathedral which holds one of
the most historic relics in the whole of
Italy the Shroud of Turin this is
believed to be the cloth that wrapped up
the body of Christ after the crucifixion
it has on it a very mysterious image you
can hardly see it if you actually look
at the cloth but then if you photograph
it and print the negative there is a
very good likeness
of a person
so what it the Shroud got to do with
chemistry and there are two reasons it
is one of the best examples of
radiocarbon dating using radioactive
carbon-14 to show how old something is
and the other reason and that's not
known to anybody before you is the Turin
Shroud is probably the subject of the
most unsuccessful experiment I've ever
done so let's begin with the carbon
dating so radiocarbon dating is based on
a radioactive form of carbon called
carbon-14 and carbon-14 is being made in
the atmosphere all the time out of
nitrogen each nitrogen atom has wait 14
and every so often really quite rarely a
cosmic ray comes out of space and hits a
nitrogen 14 and transforms one of the
neutrons the neutrally charged particles
into proton and electron and this turns
nitrogen 14 into carbon 14 and carbon 14
is radioactive and a collection of atoms
of carbon 14 have a half-life of 5560
eight years that means after that time
half the carbon atoms have decayed away
then after another five thousand odd
years but you're left with a quarter of
carbon atoms and so on so the way it
works is this carbon-14 dating only
works with things that are made from
plant material so when the plants are
growing like the grass all around me
here they are absorbing carbon-14 from
the atmosphere and so they become
slightly radioactive as soon as the
grass is cut and that grass dies it no
longer absorbs the carbon-14 and so as
the grass continues dead very slowly the
carbon-14 will decay away so if you
buried the grass and dug it up in 5,000
years time
half the radioactivity would have gone
away and if you assume that the amount
of radioactivity in the atmosphere has
been constant for many many years
then by measuring the radioactivity in
something you can tell how old it is and
you can calibrate it because you can
take pieces of wood which have rings
from the trees and you can count the
Rings and from each ring you can measure
the carbon-14 and tell whether your
calculations are correct and by and
large it works very well in the case of
the Turin Shroud it's made out of linen
linen is made at a plant called flax so
if you take a piece of the Turin Shroud
and measure the radioactivity you can
then tell when the flax plant that made
that piece of cloth died and carbon-14
dating has been known for quite a long
time since about the time of the Second
World War but the original form
you took Allah had to take several grams
of the material to measure the
radioactivity and obviously the
religious authorities who are looking
after the shrouds didn't want several
grams of it being cut off
they're already holes in the shroud
where it was burnt in the 16th century
by fire and they don't want more of them
being cut out so about 20 years ago the
techniques advanced enough so you only
needed a tiny piece of cloth and then
they measured the date but to the
disappointment of the true believers the
date of the cloth came out to be the
13th or 14th century more than a
thousand years after the birth of Christ
and therefore there's still an argument
did they take a sample from the right
part of the cloth or did they just take
a later repair so are there a lot of
people who are still arguing what is the
age of the shroud
[Music]
radiocarbon dating only works for things
that were made before 1945 we will
examine the effects on the atmosphere of
nuclear detonations
in 1945 was the birth of the atomic era
people started igniting nuclear bombs
testing nuclear devices and greatly
increased the amount of radioactivity in
the atmosphere and therefore you can no
longer assume that the amount of
carbon-14 in the atmosphere has been
constant which you need to do in order
to do carbon dating so let me just tell
you about my involvement my when I was
young my professor had a friend a school
teacher Rodney Hall who was obsessed
with the Turin Shroud and he wanted to
try and work out how the image had been
formed on it so he had a plastic model
made of his head and shoulders hollow
and he wanted us to heat chemicals from
the plastic surface where his skin would
be and try and evaporate chemicals onto
a shroud and see if we could make an
image of him so we put a light bulb
inside this head and we tried all sorts
of experiments and we could evaporate
nothing so it was a completely useless
experiment but the model of him still
exists sadly his long dead and sits in
my daughter's office at the University
where she teaches
you